MEMBER CALDERON NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA. OUR QUE HAN BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BURNER **** BATH
BONTA BRO BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CAN
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DEEP EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK
SILVA. RAMOS RAY YES
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SMITH STONE. TING VOEPEL
WALDRON WEBER. WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
. MEMBERS. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN. REVEREND PATTY OR
STAFF MEMBER NISHA. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A MOMENT OF REFLECTION.
MASS SHOOTING OF INNOCENT
PEOPLE HAVE UNFORTUNATELY
BECOME UNMISTAKABLY AMERICAN.
IN ARTICLE IN IN THE NEWSPAPER
REFERRED TO THE DAYS FOLLOWING
THE RECENT SHOOTINGS AS THE
FAMILIAR POSE SHOOTING ROUTINE
PLAYING OUT. BUT WE MUST NEVER
ALLOW SUCH HORRIFIC EVENTS TO
EVER FEEL ROUTINE. EVEN WHEN WE
FEEL OUR SENSIBILITIES
BOMBARDED BY PAINFUL EVENTS WE
MUST NOT BECOME NUMB. OR WORSE
PHIL RESIGN THAT THIS IS LIFE
IN AMERICA TODAY. WE MUST NEVER
GIVE UP HOPE TO MAKE OUR WORLD
A BETTER AND SAFER PLACE. THE
DALAI LAMA OFTEN ENCOURAGED. NO
MATTER WHAT SORT OF
DIFFICULTIES ARE HOW PAINFUL
THAT THIS EXPERIENCE IS. IF WE
LOSE OUR HOPE THAT IS OUR REAL
DISASTER. LET US NEVER LOSE
HOPE THAT WE CAN MAKE OUR WORLD
A BETTER AND SAFER PLACE. NOW
MOMMY NUMBER TWO WITH HOPE
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS. THANK YOU REVEREND WE
ASKOUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
COLLEAGUES I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. WHICH IS ONE.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
MOVING TO THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO THURSDAY
JULY ELEVENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
RECENTLY MET AT NINE AM ON WILL
KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEM OF
THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHIEF
THIRTY DAHLE THIS CERTAIN HELD
THEIR OWN MOVES IN MISTER
LACKEY SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NINE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS OUR ABSENCES TODAY
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FRAZIER AND JONES
SAWYER. MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MISSION
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE WAIT ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS LOWER
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER ALSO REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT. TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO OUT SPEAKER RENDON AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS POWER CAN.
FRIEDMAN GIPSON LACKEY SANTIAGO
AND WEBER TO SPEAK ON THE
GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RETURN ITEM NUMBER
SIX FIVE A. B. FIVE NINETY
MATHIS THE SENATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RESCIND THE ACTUAR
BY IN JULY EIGHTH TWENTY
NINETEEN SB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
SENATE AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE
WAS READ A THIRD TIME PASS IN
ORDER TO THE SENATE. PLEASE
ORDER THE BILL TO THE THIRD
READING FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER AT THE
REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORA PLEASE REMOVE ITEM ONE
FIFTY THREE SB FOUR THIRTY SIX
FURTADO FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEMS. NUMBER ONE THIRTY
THREE YES. BEFORE SEVEN NINE
AGAINST TO THE INACTIVE FILE
THE CLERK WILL NOTE. MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I'M
REFERRING AB TWO NINETY FIVE
DOLLY TO THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE. AND AB SIX NINETY
ARGUE OUR COURAGE THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY MISTER
WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YOUR
GUEST INTRODUCTION THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING JERRY LEADERS THE
YOUNG YOUNG YOUNG FOLKS UP HERE
IN THE IN THE GALLERY FROM THE
WEST UNITED DAIRY SOME OF THE
WORST THERE THERE ARE SMALL
SMALL THERE IS IN MY DISTRICT
AND SOME OF THE AIRCRAFT.
CALIFORNIA'S YOUNG GEHRY
LEADERS PLEASE WELCOME AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
WHAT IN WELCOME. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR SPECIAL POINT OF BUSINESS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
IF I COULD PLEASE GET YOUR
ATTENTION LAST NIGHT WAS OUR
ANNUAL LEGISLATIVE SOFTBALL
GAME AND IT WAS ABSOLUTELY A
HUGE SUCCESS. WE FOR THE FIRST
TIME MADE THIS A BIPARTISAN
AFFAIR ALWAYS YEARS BEFORE WHAT
WE HAD DONE WAS IT WAS
DEMOCRATS VERSUS REPUBLICANS
BUT THIS YEAR WE WANTED TO
CHANGE THINGS UP AND SO WE MADE
A BIPARTISAN. TEAM SET UP AND I
CAN'T SAY THAT I HAVEN'T HAD
I'VE HAD NOT HAD THAT MUCH FUN
PLAYING LEGISLATIVE SOFTBALL
GAME IN A LONG TIME THEY'RE
ALWAYS FUN BUT THERE WAS JUST
SOMETHING SPECIAL. ABOUT LAST
NIGHT EVERY SINGLE PERSON THAT
CONTRIBUTED. OR SEIZE GIVES ME
EVERY SINGLE PERSON THAT WAS ON
BOTH TEAMS CONTRIBUTED TO THE
SUCCESS OF LAST NIGHT. THERE
WAS NOW BLOW OUT EVERYBODY WENT
BACK AND FORTH LEAD CHANGE
AFTER LEAD CHANGE WAS EXTREMELY
COMPETITIVE IT WAS A LOT OF FUN.
AND I THINK EVERYBODY WALKED
AWAY WENT WHEN WINNING OR
LOSING FEELING LIKE IT WAS A
GOOD TIME AND PROUD OF WHAT WE
WRITE WHAT WE WERE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THE GRIZZLIES. WERE
ABLE TO TAKE THE WIN THIS YEAR
OVER THE WAYS WE VERY MUCH
EXPECT THE WAY TO COME BACK
SWING AND REALLY HARD NEXT YEAR.
BUT I WANTED TO SEC COUPLE
THINGS FIRST THIS IS AN EVENT
THAT IS REALLY ABOUT CHARITY.
WE PUT A LOT OF TIME AND EFFORT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE RAISE AS
MUCH MONEY AS WE POSSIBLY CAN
FOR CHARITY THIS YEAR ARE
RECIPIENT CHARITY WAS THE
MUSTARD SEED SCHOOL WHICH IS A
SCHOOL THAT SERVICES HOMELESS
CHILDREN HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO
AREA AND IT WAS OUR WAY AS WE
SPEND SEVEN MONTHS OUT OF THE
YEAR HERE'S HOW SACRAMENTO
BEING OUR HOME TO CONTRIBUTE
BACK TO THIS COMMUNITY. AND WE
WERE ABLE TO RAISE OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR
THE MUSTARD SEEDS GOAL THIS
YEAR AND THAT'S A HUGE
ACCOMPLISHMENT. THERE'S A LOT
OF WORK IN ENERGY THAT GOES
INTO PUTTING THIS EVENT
TOGETHER THIS EVENT WOULDN'T BE
POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE PEOPLE
THAT NOT JUST MEMBERS BUT STAFF
THAT PUT A TIME AND ENERGY DAYS
DAYS AND DAYS OF WORK INTO THIS
EVENT SO I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE STAFF. SPECIFICALLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY STAFF
THAT PUT ALL THE TIME AND
ENERGY TO MAKE SURE WE GOT THE
COOL JERSEYS AND HATS MADE IT
HAD EVERYTHING ALL THE
LOGISTICS OF REALLY FIELD.
WORKED OUT YOU KNOW AS MUCH AS
I'D LOVE TO TAKE ALL THE CREDIT
MYSELF FOR RAISING ALL THE
MONEY I IT WASN'T ALL ME. AND
WE COULDN'T HAVE DONE IT
WITHOUT OUR FUNDRAISER DAVID
PRUITT AND ESPECIALLY GABRIEL
WITH DAVID PRO WHAT'S OFFICE SO
WE CAN GIVE THEM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE FOR ALL OF THEIR HARD
WORK. HELPING US REACH OUR GOAL
OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
BUT EVERY GAME WE- IDENTIFY ONE
PERSON. ALL OF THE WINNING TEAM
THAT WE THINK WENT ABOVE AND
BEYOND. TO BECOME THE MVP OF
THE GAME IN THIS YEAR I'M VERY
PROUD. THAT ARE GOOD COLLEAGUES
FROM THE GRIZZLIES. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN MAIENSCHEIN WAS
OUR IN THE PEACE SO WE CAN ALL
GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE. MR
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE SPECIAL ORDER BUSINESS YES
THANK YOU. AS THE- CO CAPTAIN
FROM THE TEAM THAT DID NOT
PREVAIL. I DID WANT TO SAY WE
HAD A FUN NIGHT. NOT A LOT OF
INJURIES IF YOU BRUISED EGOS
HERE AND THERE. BUT YOU KNOW
THAT WAS FUNNY GAMES IN IT WAS
A LOT OF BIPARTISAN CAMARADERIE
HAVING A GOOD TIME BUT I JUST
WANT TO SAY I'M OF COURSE YOUR
HOST HERE IN THE CAPITAL CITY
IN SACRAMENTO. AND SO I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING. AND IT REALLY
WAS SO MEANINGFUL TO HAVE THE
GROUP OUT THERE THE MUSTARD
SEED SCHOOL FOR HOMELESS KIDS
IT'S ABOUT TWO MILES FROM THE
CAPITAL. WE SEE FAMILIES EVERY
DAY THAT ARE STRUGGLING IN ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES IT'S A
VEXING ISSUE IT REALLY TUGS AT
OUR HEARTS. AND WE ANNOUNCED.
WHEN WE ANNOUNCED TO TAKE TAKE
CASEY THE DIRECTOR OF THE
MUSTARD SEED PROGRAM THEY WERE
GONNA BE CHOSEN WITH INTEL ON
HOW MUCH MONEY WHAT HAVE YOU.
AND WE TOLD THEM THEY WERE
GONNA DONATES A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THEIR
PROGRAM WHICH IS. ALMOST HALF
OF THEIR ENTIRE BUDGET. AND SHE
HAD TEARS IN HER EYES. AND SHE
TALKED ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE GONNA
DO AND HOW THEY'RE BUILDING A
NEW OUTDOOR FACILITY THERE FOR
FAMILIES TO. YOU KNOW GET
PEOPLE BACK BACK IN BUSINESS
AND GET THEM IN A- HOTEL OR
MOTEL ABOUT YOUR GET THE MINUTE
SCHOOL FOR. A FEW WEEKS THERE
AT HOPE THE TRANSITION INTO A
LOCAL SCHOOL YOURSELF. IT DOES
MEAN SO MUCH IT WAS FINE BUT IT
DOES MEAN A LOT TO OUR
COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY MY HOME
TOWN HERE OF SACRAMENTO. SO
WANT TO THANK ALL OF THAT
MEMBERS THAT PARTICIPATED THAT
CONTRIBUTED ALL THE GREATER.
SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY FOR
HELPING OUT AS WELL THANKS
AGAIN AND THE WAVES WILL BE
BACK NEXT YEAR WITH A TIDAL
WAVE. THAT'S RIGHT. MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING FILE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH SIXTY THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
LIMIT FOUR EIGHT CENTRAL
202-139-4071 TWENTY EIGHT ONE
THIRTY FOUR. ONE FIFTY ONE ONE
FIFTY SIX ONE SIX FIVE ONE
EIGHTY FIVE ONE NINETY SEVEN.
1-422-223-4230 FIVE TO FORTY.
512-672-8630 THREE OH NINE.
463-583-5937 738-538-7390
SEVEN. FOUR HUNDRED FOUR OH
TWO. FOUR THIRTEEN FOUR EIGHTY
ONE FOUR EIGHTY FIVE. FIVE
THIRTY FOURTH FIVE FORTY THREE
FIVE FORTY EIGHT FIVE SIXTY
NINE FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN. FIVE
NINETY ONE FIVE NINETY EIGHT
SIX TWENTY THREE SIX THIRTY TO
SIX THIRTY SEVEN. 446-576-7767
NINE. SIX EIGHTY SEVEN SIX
EIGHTY EIGHT SIX NINETY NINE
SEVEN SEVENTEEN SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN  SEVEN SEVENTY
NINE SEVEN EIGHTY TWO SEVEN
EIGHTY SIX SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
AND SEVEN NINETY. ALL BILLS
HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
. FILE ITEM
SIXTY ONE EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY
TO THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN EIGHTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN AND
ACTUALLY TEN BY MENTAL QUALITY.
YOUR BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB SEVENTY TWO A
BILL THAT ADDRESSES THE
APPROPRIATE TIMING OF AN
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW FOR THE
TRANSFER OF OWNERSHIP OF LAND
BY A PUBLIC AGENCY TO PRESERVE
OPEN SPACE HABITAT OR HISTORIC
RESOURCES THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFIED THE CIRCUMSTANCE WITH
THE BILL APPLIES THE BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENT AND SENATE.
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
BERMAN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE RUN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE
. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTES AYE
AYES SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THE
AMENDMENTS. SALMON MANSON ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE I AM. FILE
ITEM SIXTY THREE AB THREE FIFTY
SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACTUALLY THE BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT. MR SANTIAGO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. AB THREE FIFTY SIX IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE EXCEPT
THAT SMALL CLEAR FIND TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS IN FACT A TYPO. I
RESPECT ASSN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER SANTIAGO SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WHERE WELL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WORK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY NO
SIX SENATE AMENDMENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR AB FOR
NINETY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ AS A LEGAL FOR NINETY
EIGHT BY SOMETHING MEMBER WEBER
AND ACTUALLY TO BUSINESS
LICENSING. WE WILL PASS ON FILE
ITEM. SIXTY FOUR. FILE ITEM SIX
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN BUT I'M
SIXTY FIVE AND SIXTY SIX BY
LETTING SIXTY SEVEN AB ELEVEN
FIFTY TO THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN FIFTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AND
ACTUALLY THE VITAL RECORDS MR
HOLDING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER OF
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE PEOPLE BORN IN
PASADENA LONG BEACH AND
BERKELEY MUST TRAVEL GREATER
DISTANCES TO THEIR COUNTY
RECORDER OFFICES IN ORDER TO
RECEIVE VITAL RECORDS THAT ARE
MORE THAN TWO YEARS OLD. SENATE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE
TO ENSURE ACCURACY OF THE
RECORDS ISSUED BY LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS OF HAVING THIS
BILL HAVING RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE OCCURRENCE. THANK YOU
MISTER HOLDEN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM SIXTY
EIGHT. BY LEN SIXTY NINE AB TWO
OH SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO OH SIX BY
SOME THE MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND
OTHERS ACTUALLY A PUBLIC
NUISANCE MR CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES A. B. TWO OH
SIX WOULD PROP PROTECT PROPERTY
OWNERS FROM FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS
IF THEY PARTICIPATE IN LEAD
PAINT DEBATE AND PROGRAMS.
SENATE AMENDMENTS MAKE CLEAR
THE BILL DOESN'T ALTER EXISTING
OBLIGATIONS ON THE PART OF
PROPERTY OWNERS TO MAINTAIN
THEIR PROPERTY OR LIMIT ANY
LEGAL REMEDIES AVAILABLE TO
TENANTS FOR ADDRESSING THE
PRESENCE OF LEAD PAINT. THIS
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY CITIES AND
COUNTIES AROUND THE STATE THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS TENANT ORGANIZATIONS
ENVIRONMENTAL AND HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS THE BILL'S HAD
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
IN BOTH HOUSES AND WITH THAT
RESPECT WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER CHIU
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. JUST
BE ABLE TO YEAH ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS AND
THAT'S WHEN ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES. THIS AGUIAR-CURRY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MADAM
SPEAKER AB FOR THIRTY SIX IS A
DISTRICT BILL BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE IT ALLOWS THE
HISTORIC NAPA VALLEY OPERA
HOUSE TO DEVELOP OUR
ADVERTISING SPONSORSHIPS WITH
ALCOHOL MANUFACTURERS INCLUDING
LOCAL WINE MAKERS. I WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE OPERA HOUSE IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOL
BEVERAGE AND CONTROL TO AND
SURE THAT THIS LANGUAGE IS
NARROWLY CRAFTED I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO AB
FOR SEVENTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN BY SOMETHING
MEMBER CERVANTES AND ACTUALLY
EMERGENCY SERVICES MISS
CERVANTES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN WILL
REQUIRE COUNTIES OR SITTING
COUNTIES TO INCLUDE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE AXIS
AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
POPULATION. TO ITS EMERGENCY
PLAN TO ENSURE THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND EXECUTION OF
A MERCHANT EMERGENCY PLANNING
WORKS FOR ALL COMMUNITIES I
BEFORE AN UNFORTUNATE EVENT
OCCURS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENT. THANK
YOU MISTER ON TEH SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL PEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLAND TALLIED
VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE AB
SIX SEVENTY THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTY
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS MISS
FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB SIX SEVENTY PASSED THE HOUSE
IN MAY WITH BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IT'S BACK FROM THE
SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE
CLARIFY THE DEFINITION OF
REASONABLE RESTRICTIONS TO
PREVENT ON REASONABLE COST
INCREASES AND PROHIBITION OF
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS. SB
SIX SEVENTY PROCESS AND FLOOR
WITH THIRTY NINE AYE VOTES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES ON CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU
MISS FRIEDMAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE WILL. PASS
THIRTEEN FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE A. B.
SEVEN ELEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
ELEVEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER
DAVID CHIU AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE RECORDS MR
CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE THAT
TRANSGENDER AND NON BINARY.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NO LONGER
IN SCHOOL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
UPDATE THEIR OLD DIPLOMAS
TRANSCRIPTS AND OTHER
EDUCATIONAL RECORDS TO REFLECT
THEIR TRUE AND CORRECT LEGAL
NAME. SYNONYMOUS CLARIFY THE
PROCESS FOR STUDENTS WITHOUT
GOVERNMENT ISSUED ID IS THE
REQUESTED CHANGE OF THEIR
RECORDS AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
YOU DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY TWO NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SIX AB EIGHT FIFTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FIFTEEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND ACTUALLY THE
SOLID WASTE THIS AGUIAR-CURRY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AGAIN MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB EIGHT
FIFTEEN IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
WITH AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY THE
INTENT OF THE BILL AND ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS FROM THE
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL ALLOWS
CALORIE CYCLE TO CONSIDER
WHETHER A LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS
IMPLEMENTED A DUAL STREAM
RECYCLING PROGRAM WHEN
DETERMINING IF THEY MADE A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT TO MEET OUR
STATE'S RECYCLING GOALS. DUAL
STREAM PROGRAMS RESULTED IN
RECYCLED MATERIALS THAT ARE
CLEANER IN THE WASTE STREAM SO
THAT WE CAN SELL MORE TO
PRODUCE REVENUE AND MAKE MORE
PRODUCTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
AYE ARE CURRY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY PASS AND RETAIN
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN FILE
ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN FIFTY
FOUR BY SOMETHING MEMBER
GONZALEZ AND ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT MISS GONZALES YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB FIFTEEN FIFTY FOUR
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS
BILL WAS ON CONSENT THROUGHOUT
THE ASSEMBLY AND. THE CHANGES
ARE VERY MINOR I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS GONZALES SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TWO THIRDS VOTE. MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. MEMBERS WE HAVE A FEW
ADDITIONAL GUESTS IN THE
GALLERY TODAY THAT WE LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MISTER LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
INTRODUCTION THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I HAVE COMING
OUT FROM A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THAT KATHLEEN WILLIAMS AND
DANIELLE WITH BABY SO SPECIAL
WHICH IS A NONPROFIT.
ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF BABIES
WITH CONGENITAL DEFECTS THEY
COULD STAND. ANY COULD PLEASE
WELCOME THEM I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY. MR
BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER FOR
YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTION. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES TODAY I'M HONORED TO
PRESENT THIS RESOLUTION IT
RECOGNIZING THE FORTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY OF CALIFORNIA'S
BOOK OF CALIFORNIA VOTERS
OVERWHELMING APPROVAL OF
PROPOSITION NINE THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR. AND THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION. WITH THAT VOTE
CALIFORNIANS APPROVED THE
NATION'S STRONGEST CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LAW. THIS IS THE
FINANCE LOBBYING AIMED
GOVERNMENT ETHICS LAWS ARE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT CONTINUES
A SERVICE CALIFORNIA'S
CORNERSTONE ANTI CORRUPTION
LAW. THE COMMISSION'S MISSION
IS TO PROMOTE THE INTEGRITY OF
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH FAIR
IMPARTIAL INTERPRETATION AND
ENFORCEMENT OF POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN LOBBYING AND CONFLICT
OF INTEREST LAWS. OVER THE LAST
FORTY FIVE YEARS THE COMMISSION
IS DONE JUST THAT AND IT'S BEEN
RECOGNIZED AS A NATIONAL LEADER
IN REGULATING ENFORCING
GOVERNMENTAL ETHICS ELECTION
CAMPAIGNS AND LOBBYING
ENTITIES. EVERY TWO YEARS
NEARLY A BILLION DOLLARS. TO
SPEND ON CAUGHT ON CALIFORNIA
ELECTIONS AND POLITICS. AND IN
ALL OF IT IS PUBLICLY DISCLOSED
TO THE VOTERS THANKS TO GREAT
WORK OF THE F. B. B. C. AND ITS
PARTNERS. THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE COMMISSION CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO IMPROVE CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LOBBYING IN CONFLICT OF
INTEREST LAWS AND TO ENSURE
THAT VOTERS ARE MORE INFORMED
WHEN THEY CAST THEIR BALLOTS.
JOINING US TODAY ON THE CURRENT
COMMISSIONERS OF THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION
WE HAVE COMMISSION CHAIR
RICHARD MATT IT. COMMISSIONER
FRANK CARTON THIS COMMISSIONER
ALISON HE WORD AND COMMISSIONER
BRIAN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR TO CELEBRATE THE FORTY
FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT IN THE
FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION
. MOVING BACK TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE FILE
ITEM SIXTY TWO A. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY TWO. THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
NINETY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MULLIN AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO THE GRANT PUBLIC TRUST LANDS
THE CITY OF REDWOOD CITY. IT IS.
MR MAILING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
PRESENTING AB THIRTEEN NINETY
TWO WHICH WELL FOR FILLER CRIME
IN A LAND EXCHANGE ENTITLE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION AND
THE CITY REDWOOD CITY BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS THESE AMENDMENTS
SIMPLY ADD SENATOR HELMS CO
AUTHOR INCLUDED DETAIL LANDIS
CORRUPTION FOR THE LAND BEING
EXCHANGED IN THE AGREEMENT. THE
BILL HAS MOVED THROUGH BOTH
HOUSES I CONSENT RESPECTFULLY
ASK AN AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WORK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLIED VOTE I
SIXTY TWO NEWS ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN I WANT TO
WELCOME A FORMER MEMBER WHO'S
JOINED US ON THE FLOOR FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER N'EST ANDI IS IN
THE CHAMBER LET'S WELCOME HIM.
RIGHT. MOVING TO THE. THIRD
READING FILE FILE ITEM NINETY
ONE A. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE BY
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALLY AND
ACTUALLY TRIBAL GAMING THE CAR
THERE AND SEE THEIR UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY MR GRAY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY THREE RATIFIES THE
CONTACT BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE SUSANVILLE
INDIAN RANCHERIA IT HAS NO
OPPOSITION IS STRONGLY
SUPPORTED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LAW ENFORCEMENT LABOR AND I
WOULD. URGE YOUR AYE VOTE HERE
TODAY ON THE FLOOR. THANK YOU
MISTER A SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. HOW LONG
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR
NEWS HERE ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO ON THE BILL
THE MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEMS.
NINETY TWO THROUGH ONE NO ONE
WILL BE PASSED TO RETAIN FILE
ITEM ONE OH TWO SB ONE NINETY
TO THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL ONE NINETY TWO BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND OTHERS AND
EXPLAIN CRIMES. MISS KAHN
LONGER DAD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS AS THE ONE NINE
TWO WOULD ABOLISH THE
MISDEMEANOR AND FINE OF UP TO
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR
ANYONE OVER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN
IN CALIFORNIA TO WILLFULLY OR
NEGLIGENTLY REFUSED TO JOIN A
POSSE. THAT'S RIGHT YOU HEARD
IT A LAW CRIMINALIZING THE
FAILURE TO JOIN A POSSE EXISTS
ON CALIFORNIA'S BOOKS IN THE
YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN. CAN
JURISDICTIONS ADOPTED THE POSSE
POWER IN THE EARLY DAYS OF THE
REPUBLIC AND IN DECADES THAT
FOLLOWED. IT WAS MOST NOTABLY
EXERCISE IN APPREHENDING
RUNAWAY SLAVES AND PRESERVING
PEACE ON THE WESTERN FRONT
TIER. CALIFORNIA CORPORATION
THE POSSE POWER INTO ITS CODES
WHEN THE PENAL CODE WAS FIRST
ENACTED IN EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
TWO. HOWEVER A LOCAL GRANT OF
POWER THAT WAS THOUGHT TO BE
NECESSARY DURING A TIME OF
LEGALIZED SLAVERY AND LAWLESS
FRONTIERS. IS NOT RELEVANT OR
NECESSARY IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. TODAY WE HAVE
PROFESSIONAL POLICE FORCES THAT
USE ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY AND
INVESTIGATIVE METHODS TO SOLVE
A CRIME. WE DO NOT NEED
CRIMINAL LIABILITY HANGING OVER
CITIZENS TO COERCE THEM INTO
ASSISTING THE POLICE. I DO WANT
TO MAKE SOMETHING CLEAR BY
REMOVING THIS SECTION FROM THE
PENAL CODE WE ARE NOT SAYING
THAT CITIZENS SHOULD NOT HELP
FIRST RESPONDERS AND THEIR
FELLOW CITIZENS WHEN OBLIGED BY
EITHER STATUTORY OR MORAL DUTY.
CALIFORNIANS GOOD SAMARITAN Là
REMAINS CODIFIED IN HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE SEVENTEEN NINETY
NINE. POINT ONE OH TWO. AND THE
POWER OF THIS LAWS PRESERVED
THROUGHOUT THE CALIFORNIA CODES
MOST NOTABLY IN THE GOVERNMENT
CODE AND TWO SIX SIX OH FOUR.
THIS LAW IS SIMPLY A VESTIGE OF
A BYGONE ERA IN WOMENFOLK
SUBJECTS CALIFORNIANS TO AN
UNTENABLE MORAL DILEMMA JOIN
AND POTENTIALLY PUT ONE'S LIFE
AT RISK OR REFUSE AND BECOME A
CRIMINAL. MORE OVER THIS LAW IS
A DEAD LETTER IT ISN'T USED AND
IT ISN'T NEEDED CAN WE TAKE
JUST ONE OF THESE UNNECESSARY
LAWS OFF THE BOOKS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER TOM
LONGER DOES SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
TWO KNOWS THREE THIS MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEMS ONE OH THREE
THROUGH ONE ELEVEN WILL BE
PASSED INTERCHANGE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE TWELVE SB THREE
OH FOR THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL THREE OR FOUR BY
SENATOR HILL AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE. MR MULLIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER THANK
YOU AGAIN MA'AM SPEAKER SB
THREE OF FOUR WILL ALLOW
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO
CONSOLIDATE FELONY ELDERLY AND
DEPENDENT ADULTS FINANCIAL
FRAUD CASES THAT SPAN MULTIPLE
COUNTIES INTO A SINGLE
PROSECUTION. ELDERLY OR
DEPENDENT VICTIMS OF A SERIAL
PERPETRATOR WOULD NOT HAVE TO
COPE WITH THE CHALLENGES OF
TESTIFYING MULTIPLE TIMES IN
MULTIPLE LOCATIONS AS
PROSECUTORS TRY THEIR CASE
DEPENDENT ADULT AN ELDER
FINANCIAL ABUSE IS THE FASTEST
GROWING AREA OF CRIME IN THE U.
S. AS THE BABY BOOMER.
GENERATION AGES FINANCIAL
CRIMES AGAINST THE ELDERLY WILL
ONLY CONTINUE TO INCREASE SB
THREE OF FOUR WILL ALLOW THIS
GROWING POPULATION BE GIVEN
MORE PROTECTION AND
CONSIDERATION. THE BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MULLIN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLIED VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES. WE
WILL PASS ENTERTAIN ON FILE
ITEMS ONE THIRTEEN THROUGH ONE
SIXTEEN. MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTEEN SB SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT
BY THE COMMITTEE ON LABOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT AND I PLAN TO
IMPLEMENT THE COMING THERE AND
SEE THEIR UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. YOUR CAR YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS SB SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT AS A FOLLOW UP
BUILD SB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE
WHICH REQUIRES SPECIFIED
EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TRAINING
AND EDUCATION TO NON
SUPERVISORY EMPLOYEES SB SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT EXTENDS THE
DEADLINE FROM PLAYERS TO
PROVIDE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION TRAINING. CLARIFIES
WHEN TWENTY MUST PROVIDE A NEW
EMPLOYEES AND OUTLINES WHEN
REFRESHER TRAINING MUST BE
PROVIDED THIS URGENCY MEASURES
COMMITTEE BILL THAT HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
BOOK THANK YOU MISTER KALRA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WORK WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY FIVE NEWS ZERO ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY FIVE KNOWS HERE
ON THE BILL THIS MEASURE PASSES
WILL PASS AND RETAIN A FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN FILE ITEM ONE
NINETEEN SB TWO NINETY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
OPEN. WITH AMENDMENTS THE CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY THREE WITH THE MEMBERS
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS. THIS
WICKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING
AMENDMENTS ON SB TWO NINE THREE
WHICH WOULD CREATE AN OAKLAND
SPECIFIC INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DESTRUCTION IFT THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL ENSURE THE
OAKLAND I'VE DE IS IN
COMPLIANCE WITH CURRENT
FINANCING DISTRICT LAW WHICH
WILL PROVIDE CONSISTENCY AND
AVOID CONFUSION. IN ADDITION
THESE AMENDMENTS ALSO SUPPORT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS AND
FIRE STATIONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. FAT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL OPPOSED SAY
NO. AND MENTOR ADOPTED OUT
FRONT AND BACK TO FILE. WE WILL
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
ONE TWENTY THROUGH ONE TWENTY
SIX. MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SEVEN SB THREE FIFTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY FIVE BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND ACTUALLY
JOINT POWERS. THIS AGUIAR-CURRY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY AND
PENNY PRESENTING SB THREE FIFTY
FIVE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW THE CLEAN POWER ALLIANCE
A JOINT POWERS AGENCY TO ADOPT
POLICIES THAT AUTHORIZES
DESIGNATED ALTERNATE MEMBER OF
THE AGENCIES LEGISLATIVE BODY
TO ATTEND CLOSE SESSIONS OF THE
AGENCY. THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU IS
AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. FOR WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY TO VOTE I
SIXTY THREE NOTES HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES
. MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YOUR
PROCEDURALMOTION THANKYOU
MISTER SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE SB
TWO EIGHTY SIX SENATE
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE. WE'RE
GOING TO BACK IN THE
CONCURRENCE FILE TO ALLOW THE
ASSISTANT SPEAKER PRO TEM TO
TAKE UP HER CONCURRENCE ITEM
THIS IS. FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FIVE
CORKERY. ASSIGNABLE SEVENTEEN
THIRTY FIVE BY SOME A MEMBER OF
OUR QUE HAN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO EVIDENTIARY
PRIVILEGE. OKAY HAND THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON
AB SEVEN TURN THIRTY FIVE WHICH
WAS AMENDED IN THE SENATE TO
SIMPLY ADD A CO AUTHOR. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE THOSE.
THANK YOU HIS BACKHAND SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. IT IS OUR TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO.
SENATE AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS I BELIEVE THAT BRINGS
US TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECONDI
GUESS A CALENDAR. HOUSE
RESOLUTION FORTY NINE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER KALRA AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO DOLLY. CLUB
IN THE WRONG THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER
ROLE TELL IT ABOUT AYE AYES
SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO. CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. CLERK WILL
READ THE REMAINING ITEMS ON
CONSENT SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY
NINE. I SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE
BILL TWO FIFTY NINE I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SIMPLE TO SEVENTY
ONE I SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE BILL
THREE NINE I SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SAMPLE THREE NINETY ONE I
SIXTY NO ZERO SIMPLE FOR NINETY
SIX I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SIMPLE FIVE SEVENTY I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SIX FIFTY FIVE I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SIMPLE
SEVEN EIGHTY ONE. I SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO. AND SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION EIGHT. HIGH'S SIXTY
EIGHT. NO ZERO SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS. FRIDAY AUGUST
SIXTEENTH NO FLOOR SESSION NO
CHECK IN SESSION. MONDAY AUGUST
NINETEENTH FLOOR SESSION IS AT
ONE PM. MEMBERS THE QUORUM CALL
IS LIFTED. AND WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR
. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS WE ARE DETERMINED TO
MEMORY. PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
MEMBERS
. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS ARE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE GREEN
CARPET
. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS A
RANDOM PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO REQUEST
THAT THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF ON A SODA. COLLEAGUES
THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT WE DO
HERE EVERY DAY OF SESSION WOULD
NOT BE POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE
HARD WORK OF PEOPLE LIKE ON A
SODA. ANA WAS PASSIONATE
PASSIONATE ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT CALIFORNIANS HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD THAT APPLIED IN
PARTICULAR TO PEOPLE IN UNDER
REPRESENTED AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES SHE EDUCATED
COUNTLESS PEOPLE ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF VOTING AND THEN
MADE SURE THAT THEY CAN GET TO
THE POLLS ON ELECTION DAY.
WITHOUT THEIR VOTES BEHIND US
OUR VOTES ON THIS FLOOR WOULD
BEING MEANINGLESS. ANA ALSO
TOOK PRINCIPLE STANDS ON ISSUES
SUCH AS ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
ON A QUALITY AND MOST RECENTLY
AGAINST THE SCOURGE OF HUMAN
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. HER WORK
ELEVATED HER TO THE PANTHEON OF
LATIN NEXT PRIDE ALONG WITH
YOUR PARENTS NOW. AND STILL
SODA WHO HOLD IMPRESSIVE
LEGACIES IN THIS BUILDING.
TODAY WE MOURN THAT SHE DID NOT
HAVE MORE YEARS WITH HER FAMILY
AND MORE YEARS IN WHICH TO ADD
TO HER ACCOMPLISHMENTS ON
BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN TODAY
IN THE MEMORY OF ON A SODA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. AND
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED. MISTER SPEAKER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
JOIN IN THE REQUEST AT THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF DARREN PARKER.
FULFILLING THIS NATION'S
PROMISE OF DEMOCRACY WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL HAS
DEPENDED ON THE WORK OF
ACTIVISTS LIKE DARREN PARKER HE
BELIEVES IN THAT IDEAL OF
DEMOCRACY AND SPENT HIS LIFE TO
MAKE IT REAL FOR ALL AMERICANS.
AS CHAIR OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN CAUCUS OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS
PRESIDENT OF THIS CHAPTER OF
THE NWC P. AND AS A CANDIDATE
FOR OFFICE DARREN PROMOTED A
LECTURE ON DEMOCRACY AND THE
RIGHTS OF AFRICAN AMERICANS IN
OUR STATE. HIS VISION DID NOT
STOP AT THE STATE LINE HOWEVER.
EVEN BEFORE REACHING HIS TEENS
HE WAS ORGANIZING FOR FREEDOM
IN SOUTH AFRICA WHICH WAS THEN
UNDER APARTHEID. THERE IS
HUNGER FOR JUSTICE CONTINUED
FOR DECADES AND IT CONTINUED
EVEN AS HE BATTLED CANCER
RECENTLY HIS HUNGER FOR JUSTICE
WILL LIVE ON NOT JUST IN THE
pFAMILY. BUT IN THE ACTIONS OF
THOSE WHO SHARE HIS COMMITMENT
TO RACIAL EQUALITY I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT WE
ADJOURN TODAY THE MEMORY OF
THEIR PARK. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MISTER LACKEY YOU WERE
ALSO RECOGNIZE ON THIS IS
GERMAN. THANK YOU SPEAKER
MEMBERS. I ALSO RISE TO ADJOURN
THE MEMORY OF THEIR PARKER. HE
PASSED AWAY JULY TWENTY SECOND.
HE WAS INSPIRATION ALL OF US NO
MATTER IF THERE WAS DIFFERENT
PARTY LABOR IDEOLOGICAL
DISAGREEMENT. HE WAS A STRONG
ADVOCATE FOR RACIAL EQUALITY
AND GENERALLY JUST A GOOD
PERSON. HE SHOWED THE IMPORTS
OF STANDING UP FOR WHAT YOU
BELIEVE IN. AND WORKING WITH
EVERYONE TO ACCOMPLISH THE BEST
RESOLUTION POSSIBLE. AND I
WOULD OFTEN MEET ON OPPOSITE
SIDES OF AN ISSUE THEY'RE
HIGHLY POLARIZED AND VERY
EMOTIONAL. I REMEMBER HIM
WORKING WITH EXCEPTIONAL
PROFESSIONALISM AND ALWAYS BEEN
ABLE TO FIND COMMON GROUND
DESPITE OUR DIFFERENCES. MISTER
PARKER SERVED AS A MENTOR AND
ACTIVISTS A FRIEND OF THE ADULT
VALLEY FOR MUCH OF HIS LIFE.
AND IMPACTED OUR COMMUNITY
BEYOND COMPREHENSION. HIS CARE
FOR OTHERS A STRONG SENSE OF
DUTY. AND AFFECTION SMILE WILL
BE MISSED BY ALL WHO KNEW HIM.
MEMBERS I SINCERELY ASK YOU TO
JOIN ME IN A JORDAN IS MEMORY
AND I JUST WANT TO. SAY THAT HE
RAN AGAINST ME AND I WANT YOU
TO KNOW THAT. EVEN THOUGH WE
HAD VERY DISTINCT DIFFERENCES
HE WAS A TRUE GENTLEMAN. HE
NEVER. TRIED TO ATTACK ME FROM
BEHIND YOU NEVER TRIED TO SAY
ANYTHING DISPARAGING. WE JUST
COMPLETED ON IDEAS. AND I THINK
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN
ALL LEARN FROM I GREATLY
ADMIRED HIM AND CARED FOR HIM
AS AN INDIVIDUAL AND- REALLY
CONSIDERED HIM A FRIEND. AND
HE'LL BE TRULY MESSED. THANK
YOU MISTER LACKEY MISTER
SANTIAGO YOU ARE ALSO
RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ALSO WANT TO RISE WITH
THE SATIN HEART BUT YOU HAD A
HUGE SMILE THESE ANYBODY WHO
KNEW PARKER KNEW THAT HE WAS HE
WAS JUST INTO THE ASK ABOUT THE
WORK THAT HE DID HE ALWAYS HAD
A BIG SMILE AND IF YOU BUMPED
INTO NO MATTER WHERE IT WAS OR
WHAT KIND OF CONVERSATIONAL
WHAT CHALLENGE OR
ACCOMPLISHMENT BEFORE HIM. HE'D
GIVE YOU A BIG HUG. HE WOULD
TELL YOU HE LOVES YOU AND HE
WOULD SAY LET'S BLESS THE LORD
TOGETHER. OR OR SOMETHING. THAT
THAT THAT SPOKE TO IS DEEP
FAITH IN GOD. AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT IF THAT IF WE'RE
HERE RIGHT NOW JOINING. THAT I
WOULD ALSO JUST BLOW A KISS TO
HIM. GIVE ME A BIG HUG ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATURE A BIG
KISS IN TOWN THAT WE STILL
LEVEL. THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO
AND DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. A MISTER SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS I TO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS RISE IN ACID WE JOIN IN
MEMORY OF DEER AND PARKER. WE
WERE ALL DEEPLY SADDENED TO
HEAR OF HIS PASSING THIS PAST
MONTH BECAUSE HE WAS A
DEDICATED HUSBAND A DEDICATED
FATHER GRANDFATHER A PUBLIC
SERVANT AND FRIEND. THERE I
LIVED IN ANIMAL VALLEY FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS WE WORK
TIRELESSLY WITH GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AND NON PROFITS AND
BUSINESSES TO BETTER HIS
COMMUNITY. AS ONE OF THE
FOUNDING MEMBERS OF THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY HUMAN RELATIONS
COMMISSION DEAR AND SERVED AS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE COMMISSION
FOR EIGHTEEN TERMS. HE WAS
TOTALLY COMMITTED TO TRYING TO
IMPROVE HIS COMMUNITY AND
CONTROL THE WORLD. THERE ARE
ALSO SERVED SIX TERMS AS
ELECTED CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S AFRICAN
AMERICAN CAUCUS. WAY WORK WITH
US PRESIDENTS ON VARIOUS ISSUES
INCLUDING THE MOST IMPORTANT MY
BROTHER'S KEEPERS PROGRAM WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA. IN ADDITION
THERE AND SERVED AS AN ELECTED
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
EXECUTIVE BOARD OF THE SORTIES
THIRTY SIX ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
AND REGION ONE SECRETARY OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
PARTY. HE BELIEVED IN ACTIVISM
AND HE BELIEVED IN THE PARTY
AND AS A RESULT HE PUT HIS TIME
IS ENERGY AND PASSION AND LOVE
IN IT. HE ALSO WAS ACTIVE IN
EVERY ASPECT OF HIS COMMUNITY
AND SERVES ON NUMEROUS BOARDS
ENORMOUS COUNCILS. HE WAS
PRESIDENT OF THE ANTELOPE
VALLEY IN DOUBLE ACP. AND AS A
STRONG ADVOCATE ADVOCATE FOR
EDUCATION DEAR AND RAISE FUNDS
TO SUPPORT MANY OF THE SCHOOLS
TO MAKE SURE THEY WERE SAFE. TO
SUPPORT TEAM SUMMIT ANY ALSO
SUPPORTED THE INCREASE THE
PEACE DAY EVENT RAISING FUNDS
FOR. HE WORK FOR AT AND T. FOR
THIRTY YEARS BEFORE BECOMING A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER OF THE
PARK A GROUP LLC. IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN THE AARON BECAME A
SPECIAL ASSISTANT IN THE OFFICE
OF THE ASSEMBLY SPEAKER WE
COLLABORATED WITH POLICY MAKERS
OF BOTH HOUSES TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO SOME OF
CALIFORNIA'S BIGGEST CHALLENGES.
THROUGH HIS STEADFAST
COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC SERVICE
DARREN HAS LEFT AN INCREDIBLE
LEGACY NOT JUST IN HIS
COMMUNITY BUT THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY. MANY OF YOU
PROBABLY HAVE RECEIVED FROM
THERE AND AS HE GAVE TO
EVERYONE THE RED BLACK AND
GREEN BEER THAT WAS THE SYMBOL
FOR THE AFRICAN AMERICAN CAUCUS
AND SOME OF YOU HAVE IT ON THE
DAY BECAUSE IF HE SAW YOU AND
YOU CAME AND SPOKE WITH FOR THE
CAUCUS. HE WAS GONNA MAKE SURE
THE HAD A BEER IN HIS POCKET TO
GIVE YOU. SO THAT YOU WILL
ALWAYS REMEMBER THE CAUCUS. HE
BATTLED EVEN CANCER WITH A
SENSE OF DIGNITY AND PURPOSE.
THE ARNOLD MY LAST MEETING OF
THE CAUCUS IN. OF SAN
FRANCISCO. DARREN WAS VERY ILL
BUT HE WAS OPTIMISTIC BECAUSE
HE BELIEVED HE COULD BEAT IT.
HE HAD THE KIND OF SMILE ON HIS
FACE THE KIND OF. ENERGY AND
ENTHUSIASM Là SAYS I WILL BE
HERE FOR EVER. AND I GUESS IN
MANY WAYS HE WILL. WE OFTEN ASK
WHEN A TREE FALLS IN THE-
FOREST DOES ANYONE EVER HEAR
IT. AND CLEARLY THOSE ON THE
GROUNDS HERE THAT TREE FALL. WE
ARE SADDENED BY HIS BY THE LOSS
OF HIM. HE HAS MADE IT HAD MADE
A TREMENDOUS CONTRIBUTION TO
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN CAUCUS.
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES. AND AS MANY OF YOU
MENTION IF THERE WAS A PROBLEM
DâN WAS GOING TO FIND A
SOLUTION. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE'RE JOINED IN MEMORY OF
DEER AND PARK. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER QUE HAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
THE PROUD HUSBAND FATHER
GRANDFATHER ARMENIAN AMERICAN
IN WORLD WAR TWO VETERAN UPPER
BECAUSE JOHN MORAGA. WE'RE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE HIS FAMILY
HERE TODAY TO JOIN US AS WE
REMEMBER HIM. ALBERT WAS BORN
ON OCTOBER TWENTY FIFTH
NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR IN FRESNO
CALIFORNIA TO HARY AND ROSE CAL
JOHN HE WAS RAISED IN SAN
FRANCISCO BUT SPENT MANY
SUMMERS ON HIS UNCLE'S FARM IN
FOWLER. THESE WERE SOME OF HIS
HAPPIEST CHILDHOOD MEMORIES. IN
NINETEEN FORTY TWO WHILE OUR
COUNTRY WAS AT WAR ALBERT
ANSWER THE CALL OF DUTY IN
LISTED IN THE ARMY AIR CORPS
SHORTLY AFTER GRADUATING HIGH
SCHOOL. ALBERT WOULD TELL HIS
FAMILY A STORY THAT HE KNEW
THAT GOD WAS WATCHING OVER HIM
DURING THIS TIME. HE SAID
SEVERAL TIMES HIS NAME WAS
CALLED TO GO OVERSEAS. BUT EACH
TIME HIS ORDERS WERE CANCELLED
HE BELIEVED IN ARMENIAN WAS IN
THE OFFICE WATCHING OUT FOR HIM
IN CAPTURE MOVING HIS NAME FROM
THE LAST. ALBERT MET HIS WIFE
MAY ADDED ARE MEDIAN GENERAL
BENEVOLENT UNION DANCE IN
OAKLAND AND THEY WERE MARRIED
IN NINETEEN FIFTY ONE. THEY
WERE MARRIED SIXTY EIGHT YEARS.
TOGETHER THEY HAD THREE
CHILDREN ALLEN DIANE AND ROBERT
FOUR GRANDCHILDREN PAUL STEVEN
PETER AND GIULIANA. ALBERT WAS
VERY PROUD OF HIS ARMENIAN
HERITAGE HE WAS A DEDICATED
PARISHIONER OF ST MARTIN
ARMENIAN CHURCH IN OAKLAND HE
ALSO HAD A LIFELONG PASSION FOR
READING AND LEARNING. AND WAS A
SKILLED WOODWORKER AND BUILDER.
ALBERT MADE MANY THINGS
INCLUDING INTER CAN'T ARMENIAN.
ROSS'S TWIRLING DUCKS FOR
FRIENDS AND FAMILY ARTS
PERSONALIZED TOYS FOR HIS
GRANDCHILDREN AND MOST RECENTLY
BIRD HOUSES MADE OF WINE CORKS.
ALBERT ABOVE ALL LEFT HIS
FAMILY AND HIS MOST CHERISHED
MEMORIES WERE HOSTING HIS
ENTIRE FAMILY OVER A BIG MEAL
WHICH ALWAYS INCLUDED PLENTY OF
APPETIZERS DINNER WHICH WASN'T
COMPLETE WITHOUT HIS GRANDSON
STEVENS FAMOUS ARMENIAN P. LAW.
AND DESSERTS WHICH ALWAYS
INCLUDED SEES CANDY PERSONAL
FAVORITE OF MINE AS WELL.
ALBERT LEFT HIS MARK ON THE
WORLD AND WILL BE MISSED BY HIS
LOVING FAMILY HIS COMMUNITY OF
FRIENDS AND AID THE EXTENDED
FAMILY HE LEFT BEHIND. I ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY
TODAY. THANK YOU IS PARA QUE
HAN. MISTRESS AREA YOUR ALSO
RECOGNIZE ON THIS IS GERMANY
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO MY COLLEAGUE WHO SPOKE SO
ELOQUENTLY ALBERT CALL CHEN WAS
THE SON OF ARMENIAN IMMIGRANTS
WHO CAME TO THIS COUNTRY WHEN
FLEEING THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
SOMETHING HE NEVER FORGOT. HE
WAS A PROUD ARMENIAN AMERICAN
AND AS NOTED HE WAS A DEVOUT
MEMBER OF THE ARMENIAN ORTHODOX
CHURCH AT SAINT BART'S ON IN
OAKLAND. HE WAS A SUNDAY SCHOOL
TEACHER OF PARISH COUNCIL
MEMBER AND ANY DIOCESE IN
CHURCH COUNCIL MEMBER. AND A
MEMBER OF THE TRIPLE LEX
FRATERNITY. I WANTED TO STAND
UP. IN HONOR OF HIS PASSING
BECAUSE WHILE I DIDN'T GET TO
KNOW HIM PERSONALLY HIS STORY
STRUCK A CHORD WITH ME OF VERY
SIMILARLY SITUATED TO MY
FATHER'S THE GREATEST
GENERATION THAT THAT DID
WONDERFUL WORK AND ALLOWED US
THE FREEDOMS THAT WE ENJOY
TODAY. HE CAME HERE BUT FROM AN
IMMIGRANT FAMILY BUT THEN
STEPPED UP WHEN THERE WAS A
NECESSITY AND JOINED THE
MILITARY SERVING. AND NOW WORLD
WAR TWO AS WELL AS I BELIEVE IN
KOREAN WAR ON A SECOND TOUR AND
THE- AND SO. I CAN ONLY IMAGINE
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS OF FOR THE
CHILDREN AND FOR ME TO SEE
THEIR FATHER AND HER HUSBAND OF
SIXTY EIGHT YEARS HAVING PASSED
UP BUT TO THEM I ALSO SAY
PLEASE. ENJOY THE MEMORIES THAT
YOU HAVE AND THE LIFE YOU'VE
ENJOYED WITH THEM SO TO ALLEN
DâN AND ROBERT AND MAKE MUCH
LOVE AND PRAYERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN A
MEMORY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS. I RISE
TO **** BODY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF MY FRIEND MARGIE GARY
MARGIE GARY GREW UP IN TEXAS AS
THE OLDEST DAUGHTER. TO HER
FATHER INTO HER MOTHER SHE
ENJOYED SEWING AND COOKING. SHE
WAS THE YOUNGEST SIBLING AFTER
MOVING TO LOS ANGELES IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SHE MARRIED HER
HIGH SCHOOL SWEETHEART AND
MOVED TO COMPTON WHERE SHE HAD
ONE CHILD SONYA. SHE LIVES IN
CONSTANT OVER FIFTY YEARS SHE
WORKED DURING THE DURING THE
DAY AS A HEAD START A AND WENT
TO SCHOOL AT NIGHT TO CONTINUE
HER EDUCATION LATER RECEIVING
HER BACHELOR'S DEGREE. FROM CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY DOMINGUEZ
HILLS HER MASTER'S DEGREE FROM
NATIONAL UNIVERSITY. SHE
CONTINUED OF FURTHERING HER
EDUCATION WORKED FULL TIME AND
ONE ELECTED OFFICE TO SERVE ON
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WATER BOARD AND THEN RAN HER
OWN BUSINESS CALL CREATIVE
MOVEMENT. MOTIONS GAZING AFTER
SHE SHE SERVED AS A TEACHER FOR
THE COMPTON UNIFIED SCOOTERS
GOOD HANDS AND AS EDUCATOR OVER
FORTY THREE YEARS SHE'S GIVEN
HER LIFE TO EDUCATION. AFTER
RETIRING SHE CONTINUED HER
ADVOCACY BY SERVING AS THE
PRESIDENT VICE PRESIDENT AND
THE STATE LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE COMPTON
BOARD OF TRUSTEES BUT COMPTON%
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. HER
LOVE FOR TEACHING WAS. WAS
ALWAYS EVIDENT BECAUSE HER
PASSION FOR CHILDREN AND
EDUCATION WAS SEEN DAY IN AND
DAY OUT AND LET ME JUST SIMPLY
SAY THAT SHE WAS AN ADAMANT
COOKER SHE COOKED I SHOOT YOU
COOKER BUT OFF THE THERE WAS A
THAT PEOPLE WHO ATE MEAT. MEET
JUST MELTED IN THEIR MOUTHS BY
HER COOKING AND SHE ACTUALLY
WAS A CATERER AND CATERED FOOD
FOR MANY ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL
AS EXECUTIVE BOARD IF YOU TELL
A Y. FIRST MATTER. MEMBERS I'D
JUST HUMBLY ASK THAT WE ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF MARGIE GARY A LONG
TIME ACTIVIST. SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER AND RESIDENTS OF CONTENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
GIBSON. MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES THE DESK REPORT IN
THE JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS WE
JOURNEY MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED AND RETAIN. ALL
MOTIONS SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING AND HEARING NO FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. AND MR
GIVES AND MOVES AND MISS
CARILLO SECONDS. AT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
AUGUST NINETEENTH AT ONE PM. WE
ARE JR